[Applause]
thanks very much for coming oh my
pleasure this is uh kind of an exciting
time for you because they just announced
i guess the women's world cup
in 99 is going to be here in new york is
that right yeah
first game opening ceremonies all over
the united states now is this something
where
uh you it's 99 it's still a ways off but
you start training for it now
oh yeah very competitive in fact george
and i were just in the back
slamming down a few that's how you
that's how you know what happened to
george he's my role model
he is he really him yes well i've heard
this about you you like
you know you're a great athlete but yeah
you like to have a beer every now and
then the
finer things in life live large yeah and
this
and you like uh you're a donut fiend is
that is that correct this is like uh i'm
in duncan
duncan donut heaven here in new york
it's like crazy everywhere you walk it's
like
sensory overload donut shop donut shop
you know in california everyone's like
health freaks
you have your bagel shop your juice
clubs right but you like a donut
yeah oh yeah and and you've even stopped
the i've heard that when you guys are
out on
on you know touring around playing you
stop the bus when you see a donut shop
is that right
i have that's true so it's a sickness
with you
it is it's a disease have you ever
thought i mean because in soccer you
have an advantage
your hands are free you could have a
doughnut and a beer out there while
you're playing i was thinking i could
double fist it that would be my ideal
game
now i'm curious uh about about soccer
because i
have to admit i don't know that much
about it's never been a sport that i
followed that much
is there in women's soccer is there
trash talking do you get do you trash
talk out there
uh actually you know it's different
because
you can't really understand the language
barriers is a big factor so there's not
a lot of trash talking
uh you know maybe sometimes they turn
around you pull their pants down give
them a good wedgie or something but
there's a there there's not
you know there's sort of the internet
the wedgie is an international sign
that passes passes all barriers yeah
that's that's one that that's common
with the team that's our favorite one
probably
right this is a good image for women's
soccer i like to drink beer eat a lot of
donuts
give the occasional wedgie you'll be on
the wheaties box in no time
she said good wedgie as if as if there's
a bad wedgie
well if you don't get maximum thrust
it's really not a wedgie technique to
that definitely you're telling me
that's my whole summer camp experience
was one long wedgie
i was left to hang on telephone poles
for months at a time
please let me down uh are your parents
uh
supportive are they supportive of your
soccer playing career my parents are
very supportive but
absolutely clueless which is fantastic i
mean my mom still's ongoing joke today
she doesn't know what position i play
and uh you know
she doesn't know much about the game
it's clueless it's great uh but
she did she's a nurse one time she was
watching me uh play we were playing in
jacksonville
florida it was a tv game it was like
eight degrees and we never play in the
cold i'm a california kid so if it gets
below like 70 degrees
you know i've got all the layers on and
it was eight degrees in jacksonville we
didn't have any long sleeves we had
nothing
so at halftime i said to the trainer
you've got to give me something for my
hands i think i think they're going to
fall off
you don't really need your hands in
soccer but you need them to run
obviously so she gave me these latex
gloves like surgical gloves right and
uh and your mom was watching this game
yeah my mom was watching this game and
afterwards she said to me she goes jules
did
did you have like surgical gloves on in
that game and i said
yeah mom and i said i was gonna give a
rectal exam after the game and she went
you were what you know she didn't know
you were kidding yeah she's just like
she thought this is this is part of the
sport now
nurse judy right there fruity judy i
call her uh are the the young fans uh
because
because soccer is something that you
know i see young kids everywhere playing
soccer they love it
are they the ones that are the most
rabid when they come to a soccer game oh
yeah
but and that's been the thing ever since
we won the the gold medal in atlanta
it's like
it's almost like a frenzy you know these
fans these kids
they're fantastic you know before they
were passionate about the game
but now it's like they come to these
games and you know literally after a
game they'll want to take your shoes
they'll want to take your shin guards
and i know this happens a lot with
basketball athletes but i mean you could
literally throw out these
smelly ripe socks into the you know into
the stands and they'll be like
yes you know how much do they take i
mean how much clothes and stuff do they
take
you leave the stadium naked basically
maybe
maybe that's more what they're having
about it's yeah that's right
it's possible they're not even really
soccer fans they're just like
just give us your clothes uh
are you are you uh are you super you
know speaking of uh
of some players if they play well in a
certain jersey or something they like to
wear that jersey again and again and
again are you superstitious that way
everyone always says that with athletes
that you have all these superstitions
and i
i kind of i was as when i was in high
school
back in the days when i was a youngster
uh i
wore in fact i had these uh this pair of
underwear
that had these little soccer balls on it
was so cheesy with these little teddy
bears
and uh i have those i saw him on that
video too
all right
and they and i had to wear them every
game well we ended up so you every time
every game because you wanted to win you
kept wearing the same pair of underwear
how many how many uh games in a row are
we talking about 84.
yeah okay they were weathered yes okay
so i said no more any getting the
suspicions foreign of here so no i don't
do that anymore
uh but uh i gotta mention this the u.s
women's soccer team is playing
exhibition games all over the united
states
and this is exciting the sport is really
growing fast and this is
this is going to be a huge event they're
they're touting it as
the biggest women's sporting event in
history in 1999 so it's going to be
in the rose bowl has the final in los
angeles new york the giant stadium has
uh
the opening foxboro you're from boston
that's right foxboro got a site so uh
it's all over the place it's gonna be
great all right well best of luck with
that come back and tell us
how it all develops julie foughty
everybody terry jones is coming up we'll
take a break we'll be right back
you